[Música]
osvaldo núñez ex diputado federal y
vicepresidente de la asociación
quebequense de defensa de los derechos
de los jubilados
bienvenidos a radio canadá internacional
buenos dias paulo
osvaldo a mediados de junio el 15 de
junio se llevó a cabo el día mundial de
sensibilización y lucha contra el
maltrato de los adultos mayores nos
podrías explicar tú en tanto que
vicepresidente de la asociación
quebequense de defensa de los derechos
de los jubilados cuál es la situación de
los adultos mayores
aquí en quebec
bueno fue una reunión muy interesante
que participaron por su unas 50 personas
de las cuales la mitad eran
latinoamericanos era el día de lucha
contra el mal
todos los abusos cometidos con conchas
de adultos mayores y este problema que
se vive siempre todos los países de toda
la sociedad se ha agravado con el la
epidemia de coronavirus
es preocupante la situación hay
maltratos de diferentes niveles a
diferentes aspectos por ejemplo el
maltrato a nivel sexual psicológico
financiero violación de los derechos de
la tercera edad que se están agravando
se como dije y hay que ponerle término
menos mal que esta pandemia de
coronavirus que ha sido nefasta todo
tiene un aspecto positivo que todos los
países toda la sociedad se están
preocupando más por sus adultos mayores
aquí el 80% de las muertes en canadá y
que de hecho son de adultos mayores
ahora se va a consagrar más presupuestos
porque toda justicia los quienes han
trabajado en muchos bajados toda nuestra
vida y con su vida esta sociedad que
tenemos que tener una vejez digna
y mi abuelo decía osvaldo que no hay mal
que por bien no venga
tenía razón con los sabios tenían placer
osvaldo y lo gobierno federal provincial
y municipal se han implicado para tratar
de encontrar una solución a este
problema
naturalmente es su obligación para eso
han sido elegidos y hay seis niveles de
gobierno que están preocupados por esta
problemática del gobierno federal que es
el que otorga las pensiones para la
vejez y sobre todo para los más pobres
un suplemento de ingreso garantizado en
la obligación de los gobiernos federales
que los adultos mayores tengan cómo
vivir el sabor en la última etapa de su
vida
nosotros hacemos encuestas y las dos
grandes preocupaciones de los adultos
mayores primero es la salud y segundo
contar con los ingresos suficientes para
poder vivir dignamente los últimos días
ahora a nivel provincial es de
jurisdicción provincial de este problema
sobre todo se han dictado leyes se han
creado organismos para proteger a los
adultos mayores se han hecho programas y
plan
de lucha contra el maltrato y hay
organismos por ejemplo como la comisión
de derechos de la persona que tiene dos
artículos el 10 y el 48 que luchan
contra la explotación que se hace a los
adultos mayores y a nivel municipal
las municipalidades siempre están más
cerca de los ciudadanos entonces también
hay planes y programas a las veces
anuales bianual de triana les
quinquenales de lucha contra los
maltratos de lucha contra los abusos que
se cometen contra la tercera edad de
para
favorecen la movilidad de los adultos
mayores que estén más informados que
puedan salir
recrearse porque alguna vez el invierno
muy duro aquí sobre todo el país que hay
muy largo
muchos muchos aspectos que se involucran
las municipalidades como los gobiernos
federales y como los gobiernos
provinciales
osvaldo y tú me decías que hay adultos
mayores latinos en el grupo en el que tú
te encuentras la comunidad
latinoamericana está organizada para
ayudar a los adultos
si lo hace o no lo hace cómo es la
situación ese nivel
bueno es nuestra mayor preocupación este
mundo latinoamericano que sobre todo a
nivel de la región vive una problemática
muy particular
los latinoamericanos somos una
inmigración relativamente reciente
comenzó los años 70 con la inmigración
de la gente que huía de la dictadura
después de américa central hoy día de
méxico colombia y otros países unos 150
mil personas llegados solamente a la
provincia de québec de los cuales un 15%
ya es de la tercera edad de la mediana
es 20 por ciento pero como es una
inmigración joven todavía nos llega a la
mediana ahora estamos poco unidos poco
organizados nos por ejemplo que nos
piden los adultos mayores
latinoamericanos tener residencias
específicas
para ello porque la última etapa de
nuestra vida se olvida el francés y el
inglés tuvo que aprender al llegar aquí
y ceo solamente se habla preferentemente
en español lo que hace difícil la
convivencia con otros grupos y ojalá los
con su nuevo embajadores también se
involucren en esta iniciativa de los
latinoamericanos de canadá y de quebec
de tener nuestras propias residencias
donde la gente pueda seguir sus
tradiciones su historia su religión
etcétera etcétera entonces ese es un
poco la situación de la comunidad
latinoamericana no hay muchos clubes de
adultos mayores desgraciadamente estamos
fomentando la creación de esos clubes y
por ejemplo que tengo que mencionar
ahora el camino de emaús de la iglesia
un día de canadá que figura que funciona
aquí en montreal muy bien y que agrupa
muchos latinoamericano que hace un
trabajo formidable
para distraer a los latinoamericanos
ancianos para enseñarles pintura tocar
la música escuchar la música escuchar
una pieza de teatro en fin para que
salgan de su aislamiento que se vivía
mucho especialmente en invierno el
aislamiento también queremos decir que
la
lo latinoamericano en general pero sobre
todo los que ya hemos llegado a la
tercera edad hay problemas graves de
pobreza pobreza porque no se tuvo unos
ingresos suficientes porque las
jubilaciones son bajas porque aquí casi
todos los canadienses pueden detener los
regímenes públicos de pensiones han
negociado con la función pública con el
estado con los sindicatos con las
empresas planes suplementarios
complementarios lo que no tienen lo anti
no americano porque no trabajan o han
trabajado en pequeñas empresas donde no
existen esos planes así que muchos lo
latinoamericanos que llegamos a la
tercera edad hay que galicia en ángulo
que han ido a su propio país es porque
no pueden vivir activo y dignamente con
los ingresos que tienen aquí pero esos
ingresos en su país de origen le dan
mejores niveles de vida porque el costo
de la vida es menor en esos países y
nosotros también estamos
muchos le hayan acuerdos bilaterales de
seguridad social en que esté firme
convenios entre canadá en cheque vector
que se ve que tiene una advertencia
estante de jurisdicción en esta materia
con los países de origen ya se han
firmado con chile con brasil con méxico
pero quedan muchos otros países y hay
muchos latinoamericanos aquí proveniente
de esos países que necesitan que sus
períodos de trabajo se pueden unificar
los que trabajaron en su país de origen
y los complementado con los de aquí
porque aquí se necesita por ejemplo 20
años después de los 18 años para tener
la pensión de vejez y con los convenios
se pueden reducir a 10 si alguna vez se
anular pero hay poca preocupación de los
cónsules de los embajadores por negociar
estos convenios cuando yo estuve
diputado fue una prioridad lo hicimos
con méxico y especialmente con chile
por no hay quien negociar estos
convenios y méxico
fue el primero y después chile aquí se
han negociado sobre todo con los países
industriales con eeuu con inglaterra con
francia y excelente convenio que le dan
acceso a la seguridad social incluso
cuando están en el país de origen
pueden hospitalizarse gratuitamente si
hay accidentes del trabajo u otros
también están protegidos lo que no se
hace con los latinoamericanos y que es
una gran preocupación y ya para terminar
o faldo si hay un mensaje claro que
enviarle a alguien alguna organización a
los gobiernos cuál sería
mi mensaje a la comunidad
latinoamericana que nos unamos más que
trabajemos en conjunto sobre todo en
beneficio para la protección de la
tercera dejamos afuera nuestras
divisiones tenemos tanto en común
tenemos las tradiciones del idioma
tenemos las costumbres la música el fin
y yo también un llamado al gobierno de
canadá y de quebec para que se preocupen
más de la tercera edad incluyendo
incluyendo a la tercera edad que viene
de los países latinoamericanos
en mocha al 44% de los ancianos en
montreal han nacido en el extranjero así
que tiene un problema muy específico muy
particular y pedirle también a los
medios que den más publicidad a nuestra
problemática es difícil llegar a los
medios sobre todo cuando no se habla con
el acento de aquí
gracias a radio canadá internacional
gracias a ti para uno bueno hay
muchísimas gracias a ti osvaldo por
habernos puesto al tanto sobre esta
problemática te deseo mucha suerte en
este trabajo
muchas gracias por
[Música]